bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
comme tous les lundis tout de suite le
sommaire le rugby versailles a remporté
une victoire précieuse sur son terrain
contre la grange armentières ce week-end
score final 36 à 20 le résumé du match
est à suivre dans cette édition
cyclisme le paris-nice 2015 s'élancera
pour la sixième année consécutive des
yvelines ce dimanche c'est maurepas qui
ouvrira le bal de cette 84ème édition
avec un prologue de six kilomètres tous
les détails de cette première course
avec olivier mazenc du vélo club de
saint quentin en yvelines et et notre
consultant cyclisme vienne dujarrier
pétanque le tournoi de boules élan
courtoise était organisée ce week-end au
parc des sports guy boniface à elancourt
une centaine de participants étaient
présents pour ce rendez vous tous les
détails de cet événement sont à suivre
et puis en fin d'émission tous les
résultats du week end
je vous le disais dans les titres
versailles s'est imposé ce week-end
contre la grange armentières en fédérale
3 une victoire 36 à 20 le montage est
signée romain respini c'était le match à
ne pas manquer pour versailles pour
garder une petite chance d'accéder aux
quatre premières places qualificatives
les bleus devaient impérativement
s'imposer face à la grange armentières
c'est chose faite grâce à une belle
prestation des troisièmes lignes de
versailles de l'inévitable antoine du
sexe score final 36 à 20 victoires
faciles même temps un peu dur on
s'attendait à une équipe hargneuse
agressif ça a été le cas devant ils nous
ont fait un peu mal et nous ont fait
reculer mais les beurs qu'il est dans
les ruck
heureusement on a deux trois quarts qui
nous ont fait du bien qui ont des cannes
comme tous les dimanches c'est vrai ça
nous fait remarquer des points et après
devant on a
c'est le dos rond et on a réussi à
conserver un tonneau ballon pour mettre
les trois quarts dans les bonnets bonne
situation
défaillants en première mi temps dans
les transmissions de balle l'impact
physique les versaillais ont été menés
jusqu'à la 36e minute 7 à 8 par la
grange armentières
les entraîneurs versailles et mathieu
quai vallet baptiste gouache ont dû
hausser le ton à la mi temps
l'effet a été immédiat les versailles
ont inscrit 22 points dans le second
acte ça a marché quand on a mis notre
jeu en place c'est-à-dire déplacer le
jeu loin des zones de ruck loin des
zones de conquête puisqu'une équipe qui
n'était pas en mouvement face à
armentières qui était plus volumineux
plus physiques que nous donc notre jeu
était basé sur le volume du jeu sur
l'efficacité à mettre en mouvement ce
ballon est loin des zones de combat à
deux journées de la fin du championnat
de fédérale 3 les versaillais n'ont plus
leur destin entre leurs mains pour
terminer dans le top 4 à la fin de la
saison il faudra gagner et espérer des
contre-performances de beauvais si on
gagne tous nos matches on a un gros défi
à relever face à drancy à drancy équipe
invaincue jusqu'à maintenant qui gagne 9
ici chez nous en inscrivant aucun essai
donc je pense que c'est faisable
maintenant ça le destin ne tiendra pas
qu'à nous versailles devra
obligatoirement s'imposer le 29 mars
prochain sur le terrain de drancy en cas
de défaite il faudra déjà penser à
préparer la saison prochaine
après la bataille sur le pré du stade de
porchefontaine il ira également la
guerre ce week-end sur le bitume de
maurepas pour le prologue de la 80e 84e
édition du paris-nice ce sera le temps
fort ce week-end dans les yvelines le
prologue du paris-nice 2015 est
programmée ce dimanche à partir de 13h30
dans la commune de maurepas un parcours
de 6 km 700 été mais a été imaginé par
les organisateurs pour nous parler de ce
rendez-vous nous recevons viennent du
jarrier bonsoir l'eau sont également
notre olivier mazenc membres du vélo
club de saint quentin en yvelines à
laurianne vous vous êtes champion
d'europe sur piste mais où par contre la
route ou si vous aimez ça j'ai commencé
le vélo par la route de toute façon bien
sûr ça fait partie des bases mais après
ben le plaisir est venu sur la piste
donc vous avez pu tester le parcours en
conditions de circulation quelles ont
été vos cerveaux sensation va dire sur
sur ce parcours contrairement à ce qu'on
peut voir sur le profil du site de paris
nice et bien il est plus accidenté que
ce qu'on croit et il y aura moyen de pas
de faire des écarts mais loin de s'en
tirer les premières forces en présence
sur ce paris-nice
donc nous avons filmé votre périple dans
les rues de maurepas on va le voir en
images à l'écran l'idée n'est pas de
vous faire donc découvrir tout le
parcours mais seulement quelques
difficultés du parcours de maurepas
alors le premier point clé yann c'est
une descente
ce n'est pas vraiment difficultés mais
il faut bien à présenter du coup cette
descente c'est bien ça ça va ça va
rouler très vite assurent la saison gros
là il va falloir emmené le braille à
combien vous savez je pense qu'ils vont
rouler moins 60 à l'heure il y aura pas
d ça va vraiment
elle est très très vite 64 70 et c'est
vraiment un endroit des grandes lignes
droites des grandes des grands virages
pas de pas de difficulté juste juste
quand on arrive en bas là il ya un vrai
freinage mais toute la partie
descendante va être très très rapide et
il ya une technique un peu particulière
sur sur ce virage le dernier virage mais
sur les derniers virages sur le dernier
virage oui parce que il est vraiment
fort bien de repérer puisqu'il sur la
gauche il y a un petit air plein en
pavés et donkey en plein travail en
pleine trajectoire
donc il faudra vraiment bien de repérer
pour à la main en amont pour passer
pourquoi est ce qu'on peut faire
il faut plutôt passé en intérieur ou en
extérieur sur les sensations du cycliste
c'est ça non ce sera je pense moi tout à
l'intérieur est vraiment raser le raser
la partie la partie terre plein donc
après cette descente donc il ya une
petite relance là il faudra cravacher
sur sur la ligne droite sans trop pour m
cent trente mètres sur sur la sur cette
renault on va approcher de là on
approche la bosse là on est sur une sur
une sur une relance qui précède la qui
précède la bosse donc il faut être faut
être prudent à cet endroit là commençait
juste à rentrer dans le rythme du du
prologue
parce que c'est aussi un des premiers
moments où on fait un effort en fait sur
sur le prologue puisque toute la
première partie était était sur la
descente donc là c'est vraiment juste
juste relancer pour pour se mettre dans
le rythme pour attaquer la bosse qui
arrive peu de timbres et les gens
justement sont comme en bas à ce moment
là à ce moment là gens sont encore très
fraîche
c'est le gars qui vient de débuter sir
madam t on ne sort pas du s il y en ait
eu mal aux jambes là il va passer un
sale un sale moment haut de la bosse
donc un petit mot également sur le
revêtement de ceux de cette étape à de
ce prologue à maurepas
on voit qu'il n'est pas optimal donc
comme on peut on peut le voir à l'image
justement comment vous vous êtes senti
sur sur votre vélo sur cette première
ça passe très bien c'est pas c'est pas
gênant ce qu'on voit ça bouge ça bouge
beaucoup en position de contre la montre
avec des vélos
mais les boyaux seront seront très très
gonflé c'est vrai que ça peut ça peut
sauter ça peut taper maintenant ça va
pas être là ça va paraître c'est pas par
goût mais quoi ces sourds end et des
routes qui sont empruntés très très
régulière ce type de route est très
régulièrement empruntée par par les
coureurs pros il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas de surprise
olivier bassin justement emparée pareil
pour vous pensez qu'il ya aucune
difficulté soit alors il ya vingt ans
après sur ce revêtement effectivement en
position contre la montre ça peut
beaucoup bougé il ya quelques pièges
avec ed des plaques d'égout à droite à
gauche le cirque le virage en épingle à
cheveux aussi où là il faudra faire
attention il peut y avoir quelques
risques sortie de route pour certains
coureurs qui n'ont pas y avoir des
risques de crevaison
peut-être des risques de crevaison mais
la route sera très bien balayer je pense
est un coureur qui n'a pas reconnu le
circuit en amont risque d'avoir des
certitudes et c'est peut-être un point
noir sur sur ce prologue à maurepas
survêtement ou où justement les coureurs
sont habitués à ce type de revêtement
l'audience ou six j'ai tout à l'heure ce
sont des routes qui ce type de route est
empruntée très régulièrement par parler
pour un tout au long de la saison la
particularité également de ce prologue
s'est également de longues lignes
droites comme on peut le voir à l'image
donc vous dis c est pendante est c'est
le côté agréable pour le public vraiment
ces lignes droites on peut observer les
coureurs c'est très visuel en tout à
fait il va y avoir le bas de la bosse il
y aura un très joli point de vue où on
va voir les coureurs pendant
pratiquement un kilomètre du dîner
on est déjà dans la bosse donc les gars
c'est vraiment le meilleur point de vue
avoir pour moi c'est l'endroit où il
faut être
au début de la début de la bosse la
sueur sur les 4 3 400 premiers mètres on
a un indien on est sur une piste
cyclable du coup on n'est pas non plus
très proche de 6 du coureur donc si on
avec des enfants mais il n'y a pas de
risque il n'y a pas de danger pour les
enfants
on pourra voir parce qu'on les verra
vraiment de très très loin
c'est c'est la partie la plus la plus
visuelle pour pour le pour le contre la
main et aussi le tout en haut de la
bosse sur le tout petit rond point là où
les coureurs vont couper sur la gauche
on les verra arriver de face et
et puis ils vont être quand même là des
vitesses qui seront un peu moins élevé
que sur le bas de la beauce est donc là
on les verra bien on les verra bien
aussi et dans les lignes droites on a à
peu près à combien de kilomètres de
l'endroit quoi on va dire moyens enfin
pas pour les meilleurs pour un point
courant moyen ça va déjà 50 km pour les
pour les très bons coureurs ce sera ce
sera 60 kilomètres/heure genre tony
martin ou bradley wiggins qui sont pour
moi les deux les deux favoris pour le
pour le prologue je penserai seront
autour de 100 km une fois qu'on aura
passé la boxe etc on aurai je crois qu'à
une école au niveau du bois la nova là
on sera bien relancé et là ça va
atteindre 34 ans sans souci et dans
l'image qui va suivre on tombe sur la
plus grosse difficulté donc de ce
prologue c'est la montée du donjon comme
les organisateurs l'appellent est ce que
est ce qu'on souffre justement ce dans
cette montée moi je les monte
tranquillement
donc je marque le pas depuis sa finale
pour pour la pour le tour la beauce eux
n'auront pas le choix ils seront obligés
de
devant pas de rouler à 90 % 90 95 % de
du maximum
c'est sur ce type d'effort c'est ce
qu'il faut c'est ce qu'il faut viser 6
il faut réussir à maintenir sans
dépasser le cap leucate max et c'est
toute la spécificité du d'un prologue
c'est vraiment de pouvoir rester en
prise pendant pendant sept huit minutes
à ceux à des seuils très très haut
olivier matin qu'est ce que vous pensez
qu'il peut y avoir des écarts sur dans
cette montée il dit connaissais pas le
parcours est à moi je connais très bien
pourquoi hausse et j'ai fait des courses
sur ce parcours vous êtes plusieurs
tours effectivement donc ça fait une
bosse qui fait très très mal pour un
coursier lambda on va dire je pense que
les pros ils vont la passer sur la
plaque en gros plateau il peut y avoir
des écarts effectivement leurs minima
mon sur 6 km 7 c'est pas grand chose
mais il faut savoir que paris nice c'est
le premier grand rendez vous de la
saison pour certains pros qui se prépare
pour pour le tour et ça peut être aussi
un aspect psychologique d'arrivée devant
l'adversaire dès la première étape donc
je pense qu'il y en a qui vont tout
donner pour pouvoir pour pouvoir avoir
l'ascendant psychologique pour la suite
il ya dujarrier quelques coureurs
peuvent faire la différence sur ce
prologue
comme j'étais trop - oui je vois bradley
wiggins qui qui en plus à des doses
affûté et qui a des objectifs en début
de saison sur ça il veut il veut gagner
paris roubaix
on sait que c'est quand même quelqu'un
qui prépare très bien ses objectifs
donc paris roubaix c'est dans un mois et
demi il doit déjà être en condition pour
pour marquer les esprits
en plus il a quand même une belle équipe
parce que il vient avec richie porte et
nicolas roche donc sur la sky
richie porte a remporté remporté paris
nice en 2013
c'est
je pense que voilà ils ont déjà au moins
deux leaders nicolas roche on sait qu'il
est pour l'étape de montagne sera
capable de les emmener très très bien
dans la rive pour l'arrivée au sommet ça
va être ça va être pour moi l'équipe sky
la grosse équipe du de ce tour pour le
classement général
la particularité de ce prologue c'est
également le mélange entre la ville et
la campagne
il ya du relief vraiment c'est ses
revenus tout à fait west ham au prologue
parce que on passe on passe on part on
veut le voir là vous êtes à fond cette
envie là justement
ouais je me promets vraiment sympa comme
comme petite balade hier après midi à
33,21 était bien et il pleuvait pas
c'était idéal
non mais c'est vrai que iliad - hull ne
sont pas là pour faire pour faire de la
promenade mais c'est vrai que c'est
quand même assez agréable ce petit
procès petite balade dans le bas de la
bosse c'est quand même très très
champêtre et qu'il est après c'est vrai
qu'on arrive en ville et là j'espère
qu'il y aura du monde pour pour les ans
pour un viol il ya également pas mal de
dos d'âne sur donc sur 7 sur ce secteur
vise justement à peu est-ce que ça peut
être gênant
pourquoi c'est pareil ils ont l'habitude
d'en passer maintenant c'est ça fait
partie d'une individualité qui passeront
au milieu il y aura pas de ses suppôts
je sais pas s'ils sont pas amovibles
l'acide être pouvoir être enlevé
maintenant il y en a quelques-uns qui
sont qui sont en béton ou fermées en
bitume donc du coup ils font partie du
revêtement
il passe vraiment bien ça va c'est pas
des difficultés s'est passé pas
problématique les cyclistes
on croise tous les dimanches aussi sur
sur nos courses urbaines
donc voilà on a l'habitude ça fait
partie du parti du folklore du cyclisme
maintenant comme avec les ronds-points
il ya beaucoup de ronds points 6 sur ce
sursaut sur ce prologue
mais maintenant ça fait partie des
trajectoires on sait les prendre et
extérieur intérieur extérieur et puis
voilà quoi donc on arrive sur sur la fin
de la course il y a une longue ligne
droite dans les bois c'est l'une des
principales difficultés les pouvoirs ont
usé beaucoup d'énergie
c'est après là c'est après la boisse et
c'est vraiment un moment clé peut-être
de la course tout à fait tout à fait
c'est le moment où il faudra être
capable de relancer très fort après la
après la bosse et de continuer à garder
une feinte de reprendre une vraie
allures de contre la montre
il va falloir rouler ces endroits là où
les gars ont roulé à plus de 60
ça va ça va vraiment vraiment vous voyez
c'est là que les écarts se feront parce
que ceux qui sont moins bien et bien
n'arriveront pas renoncer et celui qui
celui qui a la haca la puissance pour
pour le faire va creuser à creuser des
écarts voisins les deux kilomètres et
demi je pense jusqu'à l'arrivée donc il
ya des coureurs qui vont en avoir
d'autres en point de mire
ça va pouvoir les motiver aussi pour
rouler plus vite qua non pour vous aider
mazenc il faut vraiment la faune oui je
pense que les derniers kilomètres les
écarts vont se faire peut-être pas dans
la bosse mais après où effectivement
cela les jambes ont commencé à brûler
gore et c'est pas trop dur justement de
reprendre de la vitesse après cette
bosse moi aussi à la galilée les jambes
à son cou
c'est là que comme sur piste comme sur
piste sur un kilomètre
c'est là que la tête prend le prend le
dessus il faut il c'est pas grave on est
là pour pour se faire mal on aime aussi
se faire mal quand on est sur un vélo ça
fait partie du parti du métier comme on
dit mais faut pas avoir fait pas avoir
peur faux pas et surtout ne pas avoir de
regret c'est aussi ça quand on est sur
un vélo c'est de se dire peut-être que
j'aurais pu et bien non faut pas se dire
est ce que j'aurais pu vous dire j'ai
essayé ça n'a pas marché mais au moins
j'ai essayé et donc pour clôturer la
course une longue ligne droite
là il faut aller à fond vraiment sûr sur
les derniers mètres les délits de presse
et la chaplin droite mais avec des ronds
points à chaque fois et oui faut que ça
fasse un peu le rythme en sec tout à
fait qu'ils aient des ronds-points qui
cassent le rythme et donc il faudra être
capable de relancer après chaque
rond-point pour reprendre de la vitesse
et mais par contre on est comme on est
tout seul on est capable de les passer
sans freinage
donc il ya juste un gars y'a pas besoin
d'appuyer sur les freins il ya juste
besoin de d'aller très vite dans le
virage pour éviter un maximum de relance
derrière voyez des matin qu'il faut
avoir de la caisse sur ce type d'épreuve
oui il faut voir la caisse c'est les
coureurs qui vont envoyer de toute façon
il y aura pas des gros gros écart je
pense qu'il y aura un meilleur grimpeur
en haut de la bosse
non non j'ai pas vu sonore d'accord les
meilleurs grimpeurs ces dix mots c'est
lundi en sortant de s'arrimer château
moi ce sera des rouleurs qui vont se
faire plaisir à mon avis voix près en
ces kilomètres et demi où l'on faire du
sart quand ça compte de moyenne je pense
est à peu près ça va envoyer donc pour
résumer donc c'est une épreuve avec du
relief avec des belles courbes belles
courbes 20 lignes droites où les
spectateurs pourront voir les coureurs
donc je pense que les enfants ont les
yeux écarquillés parce que voir des
découvertes comme ça c'est pas donné
tous les jours donc en ville ça peut
peut-être faire des émules derrière et
donc justement les organisateurs ont
choisi maurepas pour pour sa plus tant
pour sa variété au niveau 2 voilà du
relief même
au niveau visuel entre les bois etc je
pense que c'est un parcours qui a été
étudiée c'est une belle bosse un beau
parcours
donc à mon avis ça va faire un très beau
prologue
yann est ce que ça peut être injustement
un tracé qui peut plaire aux coureurs je
sais leur jeu ne fait un plat au pouvoir
certainement oui
maintenant je pense que samedi sur les
repérages il y en a quelques-uns qui
vont avoir une surprise parce que quand
on ferme le profil comme l'idée de début
d'émission quand on doit s'attendre à
des surprises en fait ça pour vous non
mais vous non parce que ça passera et ça
changera rien mais quand on regarde de
profil on voit vraiment un pro tout plat
et quand on y arrive
eh ben il n'est pas plate du tout et
donc ça s'il est connu sur sur certaines
épreuves
quand on arrive tranquille et puis bah
non il ya toujours un petit piège
et c'est vrai que ben là ça va être la
seule surprise ce sera le samedi ou le
samedi sur le rallye et matin comment
vous allez vivre justement ce
rendez-vous sera avec un mur avec
passion un mois je suis tombé en tant
qu'amateur away en tant qu'amateur là
bas moi je connais très bien le circuit
je suis mort pas donc j'ai l'habitude de
tourner là je fais pas mal de course sur
ce circuit l'a donc des courses d'usure
et de voir les pros monter cette bosse
une plus grande vitesse que moi en
position contre la montre je pense que
et se confond même si relanceront je
pense que sa ferrari c'est les poils et
ça va faire ça va faire quelque chose
mais vous pensez qu'il y aura beaucoup
de monde
pourtant il y aura beaucoup de monde
c'est un circuit en ville fermée je
pense que ça va tirer j'ai remis à des
personnes ou pense et j'espère j'espère
que mes saisons clairement répondront
présents comme ils l'ont fait pour pour
championnats du monde de cyclisme la
semaine dernière ils ont car prologue en
ligne comme ça c'est plus sympa que
celui qui avait eu dans la veille
chevreuse ou là les gens doivent se
déplacer là vraiment c'est circuit fermé
on pourra se garer on pourra venir à
pied en sécurisés comme tu l'as dit sûr
avec la la piste cyclable leur a la
bosse donc hélas oui les coureurs qu'on
pourra voir de loin ça fera du beau
spectacle
un mot également sur saint rémy les
chevreuse c'est également une étape qui
part des yvelines deux emmy deuxième
étape enfin première étape au final avec
un prologue est ce que saint rémy les
chevreuse vraiment
le parcours aussi l'idéal est ce que
c'est le lieu idéal pour la pratique du
cyclisme en finale la vallée de
chevreuse tous les dimanches les
automobilistes nous haïssent
trois dépôts ton de 30 40 c'est vraiment
le lien entre justement les amateurs et
les professionnels a fait c'est avec
leur c'est même à l'enfant les gens
parlent de laver de chevreuse vont faire
des balades en vallée de chevreuse il ya
des pros qui est tony gallopin il va y
arriver
fredo voilà et sur cette première étape
qui partira 5 me cheuvreux c'est là
qu'on va voir aussi notre premier duel
entre nos deux sprinteurs français qui
étaient à la fdj l'année dernière et qui
donc un an sont séparés l'un chez
cofidis et donc nacer bouhanni et
d'arnaud démare qui est toujours à la
fdj
un bond dû à un beau duel mais bon qui
va être arbitré par andré greipel il ya
vraiment un très haut niveau
il ya aussi john de galles pop qui était
leader du maillot du maillot vert
l'année dernière sur paris nice une très
belle une très très belle confrontation
et peut-être même un petit arbitre qui
star qui est nôtre notre bryan coquard
nationale et donc voilà il va y avoir du
beau spectacle aussi sur l'arrivée de la
première étape lundi
ça va être aussi les enjeux du les jo de
paris nice là on va avoir des bobos
sprint des beaufs dernier merci à tous
les deux d'être passé sur ce plateau il
ya dujarrier également verser à oublier
mazin qui est ce que vous êtes fan de
paix tant que yann moix je suis content
de tous les sports la paix tant que bien
sûr c'était c'était mon enfance avec mes
parents j'adore ça du coup on va parler
donc de la compétition la boule élan
courtoise
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler pétanque aujourd'hui dans le 7-8
sport la compétition la boule élan
courtoise était organisée ce samedi au
parc des sports guy boniface à elancourt
patrick jacques de dixmude dick smith de
programmes pour pour les unes et les
images pardon un mistral du sud a
soufflé sur elle en cours samedi dernier
le parc des sports guy boniface est
transformée le temps d'une journée en un
terrain de jeu de boules aux géants
digne des plus grandes heures de la
compétition la marseillaise au total
près de 200 pointeurs et tireurs du
département se sont donné rendez vous
pour cette journée qualificative pour
les championnats de france
vous avez toutes catégories mêmes élites
gratin de la pétanque n'y a pas de
grands joueurs connus mais il ya quand
même du bon des idées ce combiné le roi
vous avez aubergenville ou du rassemble
la majorité des bons éléments du sur dix
huit essais pour un qualificatif pour la
ligue donc à partir de là le premier
d'ici parce qu'il ya on en retient qu'un
concours individuel il est qualifié pour
le championnat de france
petite particularité de cette
compétition les manches sont organisées
sur le principe du tête à tête
le concept un joueur affronte un autre
joueur sur une partie le gagnant est
qualifié pour la manche suivante tête à
tête votre faute de cool qu'il faut être
concentré sinon son principal
on pointe mal ou au tir mal sa part l'on
peut pas gagner il faut savoir faire les
deux c'est très technique je trouve
parce qu'il faut savoir plaintes
éthérées analysé le jeu donc technique
alors oui je suis plutôt pointeuse
pointeuse de tête et milieu quand je
suis en triplettes
parce que en effet chez un petit red
bull mais mon poste favori c'est
pointeuse temps le soleil et les
apéritifs au goût anisé mais sous la
grisaille de la région parisienne
l'objectif est atteint rendez vous
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition
du côté des résultats c'est le joueur du
mesnil-le-roi stéphane la fontaine qui
se qualifie pour les championnats de la
ligue
voici nos didier d'aubergenville à lui
remporté le challenge
on passe maintenant résultats du week
end
au rugby nouvelle défaite pour plaisir
le rcp s'est une nouvelle fois incliné à
l'extérieur sur le terrain d'orléans le
score 20 à 13 une défaite qui va laisser
des traces les hommes de pierre vidalis
compter sur cette victoire face à un
adversaire direct pour le maintien pour
se relancer totalement dans ce
championnat de fédérale 2 du côté du
classement rien ne bouge le plaisir est
toujours avant derniers du classement
avec 13 points en 16 matches disputés
montée l'année dernière en fédérale 2 le
rcp ne devrait vous devrez faire
l'ascenseur cette année pour descendre
en fédérale 3 en basket trap a réussi le
gros coup de cette 18e journée de
nationale 3 les hommes de mustapha el
hafidi se sont imposés avec la manière
sur le parquet de gennevilliers deuxième
du classement
score final 93 à 90 pour les trappistes
de son côté le chesnay versailles s'est
une nouvelle fois lourdement incliné sur
son terrain face à vineuil sur le score
de 92 à 60
du côté du classement trappe roman tu
remontes les hommes de mustapha el
hafidi se retrouve à la 7e place du
championnat à cinq petits points du
deuxième gennevilliers les trafics sont
plus que jamais en embuscade pour la
montée le chesnay-versailles se dirige
tout droit vers la relégation et
versailles et sont avant derniers du
classement avec 26 points
toujours en basket mais chez les filles
cette fois rien ne va plus pour le
chesnay versailles et versaillaise ne se
sont très lourdement incliné sur le
parquet du poinçonnet 76 à 4 43
l'attaqué a été une nouvelle fois en
berne avec seulement 43 pour l'inscrire
dans la rencontre
du côté du classement l'entente le
chesnay-versailles n'en finit pas de
rodez de descendre les versailles les
versailles et son dixième du classement
avec 21 points à égalité avec arras une
très mauvaise saison pour l'entente chez
les filles comme chez les garçons la
relégation est fortement envisageable
en football américain les templiers
d'elancourt ont concédé leur deuxième
défaite en trois matches cette saison à
domicile les élans courtes ont été
terrassés par les black panthers de
thonon-les-bains
score final 42 à 39 les templiers
favoris de ce championnat n'ont toujours
pas gagné un match cette saison
et puis ce week end deux rendez vous à
ne pas manquer il y aura du football
donc ce week-end trappe reçoit
saint-ouen-l'aumône ce dimanche à 15h30
au stade de gilbert son sac un match qui
s'annonce compliqué pour trappe
huitième du classement qui reçoit le 4e
de cette promotion d'honneur et
trappistes doivent l'emporter pour
espérer se maintenir
l'année prochaine dans ce championnat on
en parlait dans cette émission le
prologue de la 84e édition du paris-nice
et organise ce dimanche
le départ sera donné à 13h30 5 rue de
montfort le parcours fait six kilomètres
des milliers de personnes sont attendues
pour cet événement c'est la fin de cette
édition merci d'avoir suivi je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles aventures sportives excellente
soirée sur téléphiles à 78